Now we're done with decorators, and I want to go back to languages.
The first thing I want to say is that our culture is full of stories of wishful thinking.
We have the story of Pinocchio, who wishes to be a real boy,
and the of Dorothy, who wishes to return from Oz to her home in Kansas by clicking her shoes together.
They find that they have the power within them to fulfill their wishes.
Programming is often like that.
I'm righting the body of the definition of a function, and I wish I had the function "fib" defined already.
If I just assume that I did, then eventually my wish will come true.
In this case, it was good while writing the right-hand side to just assume I wish I had the function I want
and proceed as if you did, and sometimes it's a good idea to say I wish I had the language I want
and proceed as if you did. Here's an example.
Suppose you had to deal with algebraic expressions
and not just compute them the way we can type this expression into Python
and see its value if x is defined but manipulate them.
Have the user type them in, modify them, and treat them as objects
rather than as something to be evaluated.
Now, my question for you is it is possible to write a regular expression
which could recognize expressions like this that are valid.
Is the answer, yes, it is possible to write that?
No, it's not possible because our language we're trying to define
has the plus and asterisk symbols and those are special within regular expressions?
Or no, we can't parse this language because this language
includes parentheses, and we can't do balanced parentheses for the regular expressions.
If you're not familiar with language theory, this may be a hard question for you,
but go ahead and give it a shot anyways.